here's muncie where's the famous meeting
between these two guys get it out of the
ocean home run
muncie barked at him the whole time
around the bases
so here they are we meet again
[Applause]
and mad bum wins this one with a
curveball
facing the diamondbacks for the first
time this year first career start
against them
that ricochets off may and rojas will
lead off the game with a hit and dustin
in some pain
gets him right on the inside of that
left foot and now he says to possum and
dave roberts i'm okay
let's play on
here's his 1-2
off the end of the bat right side
ranging over there is bats unable to
scoop it up and walkers aboard
first chance that he gets is a tough one
yeah just a dribble on the end of the
bat and mookie was playing a little bit
up the middle of the field would have
never had a chance to get him anyway but
he ended up getting to the ball and then
actually tumbling over it
single for smith two one and two down
now for austin barnes
high in the air toward the corner and
left peralta near the bullpen drifting
over there and he's got to try to get
everybody ready for the postseason
rather than
milk the guy through a start when he's
obviously not right they apparently
didn't like what they saw in the warm-up
pitches the way he was landing on that
left foot so they're going to get him
out of there
yeah dave roberts wasted no time and so
may
will leave
as a precaution 2-2 count on ahmed with
peralta at third and no ounce
and nick chases a fastball outside the
zone and strikes out got to find a way
to get david home here
it's a high fly ball to right field
on comes hernandez and gonzalez out of
the inning unscathed corey seeger coming
up and seeger with a single to center in
his first at-bat bum grinder is seeger
with the 1-1 pitch
corey lifts it to left back towards the
corner goes peralta it's gone
just over the wall for corey seeger and
a home run has the dodgers in front one
nothing those are the ones as pitchers
and you can see bumgarner saying are you
kidding me gets over by that much it's
seeger's 12th
aj pollock with one away hits a fly ball
to left field back goes peralta he's at
the track he's at the wall they go
back-to-back seeger and pollock
back-to-back solo home runs and the
dodgers lead bumgarner in the d-backs
two-nothing boy has aj pollock turned
into a great hitter this year for the
dodgers this is the old aj pollock well
you got three four and five coming up
second and third nobody out down two
nothing walker
singled his first time up tonight
hard to third that's by muncie and down
the line
rojas is home here comes van meter
christian walker a two-run double and we
are tied at two
but that's not intentionally to load the
bases up for seeger
iron to second van meter ahmed for one
double play they got it
and med bomb wiggles off the hooks ahmed
making him work this is the eighth pitch
it's grounded past him get your foot out
of the way
that's a diving stop but no chance at
throwing
it's
nothing routine for him tonight nothing
no ground ball right at me where you
play second base everything an adventure
look out off mad bum
and right to christian walker hopefully
madison is okay that was a shot right
back up the box and he's laughing about
as he heads off the mound
and that'll go one to three on the put
out at first the ending over dodger
sleeper runner running for wood he's the
first guy to pitch multiple innings
his first one to calhoun is ripped
sharply that's with the routine
opportunity how about that and he makes
it cleanly been an adventure of a night
in his first game at second base his
first start there since 2014.
it finally gets one that's not a weird
play hernandez walk and the go ahead run
aboard
smacked on the ground base hit center
field hernandez thinking aggressively
heads for third the throws cut off smith
back to first ow
first and third one out and betts who
has been one of the best players in
baseball this season overall has been
particularly good with runners in
scoring position barnes takes off carson
kelly throw here comes hernandez the
throw to the plate
got him at home
another outstanding defensive play by
the diamondbacks here tonight another
3-2
ball four
oh
i don't know
something strange going on there
yeah here we go bob garren probably just
caught it he said doc four balls should
be first base all right here you go
it was ball four all right and i'm not
crazy
ahmed will go to second base
marshall gets into one
right field and it's off the wall ahmed
had to hold up he's coming around third
dalton vargo digging for third hayes in
there with an rbi triple
and it's 3-2 diamondbacks
infield creeps in carson kelly
arson kelly hits a fly ball deep left
field that ball is gone
carson kelly a two-run home run and the
diamondbacks open up delayed here in the
sixth
the third of the year for carson make it
five two diamondbacks so bergen is one
out away and the batter is chris taylor
popped him up nick ahmed behind
shortstop
and travis bergen closes out of 5-2 in
behind riley smith some dynamic d-back
defense
and the diamondbacks win a
series and season finale with the boys
in blue